valérie plantes de projet montréal
connaît déjà le premier geste qu'elle va
poser si elle devient mairesse le
lendemain ça va être le transport pas
vain d'acheter 300 autobus hybrides pour
mettre sur la route
elle veut mettre 300 autobus de plus en
circulation mais elle dit que denis
coderre veut en ajouter seulement 38
on avait deux filles projet montréal y
est allé d'une infographie sur les
réseaux sociaux
valérie plainte 300 autobus dénis
coderre 38 ont déduit que valérie
plantes propose de développer plus chez
les transports en commun que denis
coderre lui en a moins ok ce cas plus
pour le transport en commun
en fait ce que la stm prévoit sous denis
coderre ses maîtres 347 autobus de plus
sur les circuits de montréal d'ici 2025
ça a été annoncé à la fin du mois dit
valérie plante elle demanderait à ce que
300 autobus soient ajoutés mais pas
d'ici 2025
ce serait d'ici 2020 alors vous l'aurez
compris valérie plaindre vu que les
autobus supplémentaires arrivent plus
vite sur le réseau
mais quand elle dit qu'il n'y aura que
trente huit autobus au cours des quatre
prochaines années si denis coderre est
réélu c'est parce qu'elle calcule
seulement des autobus électriques qui
sont dans les cartons pour 2019
mais la stm elle n'a toujours pas
annoncé le nombre d'autobus hybrides
qu'elle compte acheter en 2019 ou encore
en 2020 c'est donc impossible de dire le
nombre d'ajouts pour les quatre
prochaines années
si vous voulez qu'on se penche sur
d'autres sujets et queen
[Musique]